what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and i just got out of
the mandalorian panel here at star wars
celebration in anaheim california they
showed us footage of the ahsoka series
which was so unexpected and they also
showed us footage for the mandalorian
season three now on thursday they
already showed us this footage but they
added an additional 30 to 45 seconds of
new footage so if you heard a
description of the mandalorian season 3
trailer or footage this is actually
going to be a bit more than what you've
heard before they didn't technically
call it a trailer it looked like a
trailer probably what they'll use as a
trailer but regardless i'm going to tell
you exactly what i saw obviously there
are no recording devices allowed when
the presentation is up so we don't link
it online but we can tell you exactly
what we saw so here's my description of
the ahsoka footage that we saw in the
mandalorian season 3 footage that we saw
which i believe
is
hands down one of the best things to
come from star wars it blew me away it
was fantastic so if you love star wars
if you love marvel if you love all
superhero stuff be sure to subscribe and
hit that bell so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos alright so
starting with the ahsoka footage that we
saw they didn't show us much the clip
was only about 35 seconds long but what
they did show us the non-filler stuff
was pretty cool the first thing that we
see is ship doors opening up and it
reveals the bridge of the ghost we then
see hera from behind walk onto the
bridge and right behind her is ahsoka
walking onto the bridge as well then it
fades to black then it shows us more of
a ship and then it shows us somebody
sitting down they have their arm on a
table and their hand is out reaching for
a cup trying to use the force to bring
it to them now no one was actually shown
here it was just the arm of the person
but i know it wasn't ahsoka because i
remember that the hand and the arm
weren't orange so this person is a
mystery as of right now they then show a
droid and i don't believe i've seen this
droid in clone wars or rebels or
anywhere before so i'm gonna say it's a
new droid and he's only shown very very
briefly but here's where things get
pretty interesting we see ahsoka and she
has her hood on then she takes her hood
off and she's looking at somebody she
then tilts her head forward and closes
her eyes almost kind of like she's
bowing at somebody or saying hello but
it definitely looks like it's a sign of
respect that she's doing so i'm
wondering who exactly this could be
we've already had a crossover between
ahsoka and luke in boba fett so really a
lot of things are possible here and
here's where it gets even more
interesting after the title card ahsoka
shows we see a mural in the mural we see
hera ezra sabine wren zeb and kanan this
of course is sabine wren's mural and to
my knowledge from what i saw it is the
exact same one from rebels but as
they're showing the mural we see
somebody come up who is staring at it
and this person is sabine wren and they
did announce that sabine wren is going
to be played by natasha luis bordizzo so
super exciting news there and that's
pretty much all that they showed us in
the ahsoka footage just some footage put
together for the fans at star wars
celebration but definitely a big big
teaser with a lot of hints of some
awesome things to come now as far as the
mandalorian season 3 footage we actually
saw this trailer twice today so i've
seen it three times now once on thursday
and twice today with the extended
footage and i made sure to make some
notes immediately after i saw it so the
beginning is pretty much the same as the
trailer they showed us on thursday and
it opens up with the mandalorian flute
theme plane we then see the mandalorian
walking through what looks to be
destruction and based off of what they
showed us in this trailer this is
probably mandalore and he's kind of
walking through the destruction after
the night of a thousand tears and then
we hear the armorer speak and this is
what she says she says you have removed
your helmet what's worse is that you did
so of your own free will and after she
says that it shows footage of grogu and
that's kind of to show us why he removed
his helmet but she continues to say you
are no longer a mandalorian she then
says redemption is no longer possible
for you since the destruction of our
homeworld we then cut to a scene of the
mandalorian going up to bogatan who
seems to be sitting on some type of a
throne we have never seen this room
before and she said something along the
lines of you and your people gave them
mandalore where were you then and i
believe she actually calls them his cult
i think she says you and your cult so
she's pretty bitter she's pretty pissed
off and you can tell that there's just a
ton of tension between her and den then
it looks like the mandalorian returns to
navarro because there he sees grief and
grief karga looks like he is doing
extremely well for himself and when
grief sees him he laughs and he says i
heard you were back but i didn't believe
it and greets him very warmly and very
welcoming then we hear the mandalorian
talk and he says i'm going to mandalore
to be forgiven for my transgressions i
believe he's talking to bogotan and it
actually looks like maybe she's going to
help him maybe she has ulterior motives
but it does look like she is helping him
and we see her kind of in like a cave
where she shoots the top of the cave and
it creates a hole and kind of the
ceiling just falls down and when it
falls she turns and she looks at grogu
and she said did you think your dad was
the only mandalorian and from here we
just get a ton of footage and this
footage is just completely action packed
we see it both on planets and off
planets in space we see a starship fight
in an asteroid field we see a star
destroyer we see a ton of mandalorians
coming together and fighting together
and i mean a lot in the footage we saw
alone there were probably about 20
different mandalorians that we see and
then at the very end after all of this
epic footage which is just a ton of
action we actually see
mandalore we see it in the ruins that
are left of it but it was so insane to
actually see mandalore and that was it
it was actually about i would say
probably close to three minutes long
probably like two minutes and 40 seconds
and again they didn't call it the
trailer but it is a trailer it's a full
trailer put together just like a trailer
typically is and i'm hoping this is
released pretty soon they did confirm
that the mandalorian season 3 is going
to come out in february of 2023 so
hopefully this trailer isn't too far
along from being released to the general
public but that is what we saw it was
awesome and let me know how excited you
are for this trailer to finally hit and
how excited you are for the ahsoka show
and the mandalorian season three let me
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for more
star wars marvel and other awesome
videos be sure to subscribe for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
[Music]